hey guys Pete here let's do another Game
of Thrones Season seven video today HBO
released some news photos for episode
two and they got me thinking about Arya
plus some of the comments that you guys
made in some of the conversations we had
so this is basically going to be a
discussion about Aria's path for this
season and it won't really have any
spoilers other than what we've seen from
the promotional stuff from HBO itself so
last week we saw that she was in the
twins still after killing Walder Frey
she used the new skills that she
acquired over in Braavos to where his
face and destroy the rest of his male
heirs at least that's the way it came
off from there we saw her in the
Riverlands with some Lannister soldiers
and I guess this is where we first
learned of her intentions to go south to
King's Landing now a lot of people would
like to see that because that would mean
that she's going to actually kill the
Queen like she said she was going to as
you go to the soldiers but that's really
not very probable when you think about
how much time's left and how unrealistic
it is for the story to be that beginning
of season 7 Arya goes down kill Cersei
and then it still carries on beyond that
so why does she meet the soldiers and
that was the question that popped up in
my mind and I think from a storytelling
perspective it makes a lot of sense she
meets these guys they're very welcoming
to her in a lot of ways compared to
other meetings we've seen on the roads
in Westeros so I think she's likely safe
but I think what's important for this
part of the story is that she'll
probably learn from them that her
brother Jon has been named King in the
north
obviously they had contact with the
crown of King's Landing and that would
be the kind of thing the kind of news
that would come that would have her
change her path now we did get this new
photo in that batch from HBO of her in
front of what looks like a tavern or an
inn and I can't say that this tells us
anything conclusively but it looks like
she has a look on her face like where
she's trying to decide go south try to
kill the Queen or
NORs and reunite with her family she has
every reason in the world to want to
kill Cersei but it's just not very
likely even with what she has going for
her now with the faceless man skills
it's still a tall order to infiltrate
the Red Keep and everything else that
goes along with that
now I had a comment earlier on the
trailer breakdown about Edney er we
don't exactly know where head Muir is
other than the phrase have him or he was
under the phrase control I should say
but I assume that there may be a
situation where she frees him but we
haven't really seen anything from the
official stuff to say that that's the
case I don't think he'll be a big part
of the season or next season beyond that
but I think he does sort of need to be
liberated
now that the phrase are no more now the
big thing that popped out to everyone in
the teaser trailer for episode 2 was
this shot of a wolf that looks like it's
cut together with Arya looking at the
wolf I did talk about this about how I
don't think it's 9 area per se in my
trailer breakdown and I think that's
across the board a pretty consistent
theory at this point that it's actually
a member of the pack not Nymeria herself
but yeah watch that other video if you
want I don't want to get into that too
much so watch that one to learn more
about that but that that isn't really a
it doesn't really tell us which
direction she's going I mean we know
from at least the books and other clues
that Nymeria is in the Riverlands
so whether she goes north or south it
doesn't really matter she could still
run into her pack one of the other
things though the big evidence I think
for her going north rather than south is
the trailers and the other set photos
that have been officially promoted by
HBO we see her in the cold we see her
lighting a fire in one of these photos
we see that very first clip that we saw
from the new season where she's looking
she's looking in a very cold looking
place but she's looking out over
something that I have a strong feeling
that that's probably Winterfell so all
of that definitely points to her going
north and I don't think it's a red
herring
I don't expect that the roads of King's
Landing will be this engulfed in the
north by the end of the season but we
don't really know other things have
notes that people may be wondering there
was a lot of talk last year about this
Melisandre conversation and it happened
in season 3 if I recall correctly about
seeing each other again so there was a
lot of speculation on whether Arya would
be headed north and Melisandre would be
headed south and they would cross paths
well it seems like it's a good idea I
don't really know that there's anything
that says that's going to happen in the
trailer we did see that Melisandre is at
Dragonstone so we know she makes it
there and I don't really know how that
would go down if they did running into
each other so there's an off chance that
might happen but I'm not thinking that
it will also since Joe Dempsie showed up
at the premiere people know that Gendry
is probably coming back even those of
you guys who didn't follow spoilers or
anything else and I think this is the
same thing I don't know that if she ran
into him like say he was still at the
end or here somewhere I mean that's
already in the books but say they ran
into each other on her way north that
would change the path pretty
significantly or have the potential to
or it would just be weird if they just
said hey what's up and then they kept
going on a separate way so my thought is
is that it will probably not happen they
probably won't get together not on her
way north anyway the other thing that
we've seen we saw a photo of Jon here
what it looks like he's leaving
Winterfell with all those it's not a new
photo but it was re-released I mean it
might be new in the same scene or
whatever but the sad part of all of this
is is that if she's going north to catch
up with Jon it looks like he's not going
to be there when she gets there we've
seen hints that the dragonglass is
important to him
the Samwell sent him information about
Dragonstone also now that Daenerys has
landed she's probably going to call for
fealty were you know different people so
history that this trajectory is
definitely south we also got this photo
of Shawne sustained
they're looking out over the yard at
Winterfell that is likely her watching
John Doe that sets up this dynamic where
it's just to earn little finger in
Winterfell and that's why it's pretty
good that we have brain and Aria headed
that direction
those pictures also shows that there's a
falling-out between and we saw this in
the trailer as well but there's a
falling out between Littlefinger and
John or at least Littlefinger anger
stand before he goes south so he'll be
at full-scale scheming mode so I think
Arya is going to be necessary to balance
things out there at Winterfell even
though we don't really know how that we
don't really know how that reunion is
going to go it's going to be a very
interesting situation I mean the best
reunion that we want is the one where
Jon and Arya get back together but I
think that still a ways away so it's
going to be very interesting to see
these two sisters who didn't always go
get alone but well there yeah they
didn't really get along at all but they
both grown and they both gone through a
lot so there's a lot of potential for
cool stuff to go down between them in
the name of their family in the name of
their father and their mother and
brother Robb and all these people so in
conclusion I think her saying she's
going south is completely false I'd be
really surprised if I'm wrong but let me
know what you guys think I mean the
trailers pretty much spell it out for us
right do you think ed Mir will get into
the mix somewhere or do you think that's
just sort of like a loose end that needs
to be tied up and what do you think is
going to happen when these two sisters
get together in their home after all
these years
all right guys please like the video if
you enjoyed it please subscribe to my
channel follow me over on Twitter and my
other social media accounts to keep up
with what's going on make sure you let
me know what you're wanting to see and
thanks for watching I'll talk to you
soon